thierry coville bonjour oui bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france on le
disait le négociateur européen pour le
dossier nucléaire attendu à téhéran qu'à
tonnes de cette visite alors que les
discussions sont au point mort
aujourd'hui
des comment dire des garanties des
déclarations de la part de dirigeants
iraniens qu'ils vont bien effectivement
reprendre les discussions à vienne pour
pour aboutir à au retour des etats-unis
dans l'accord du week-end pourquoi
l'arrivée du président et bahreïn raïssi
a paralysé les discussions ces derniers
mois
c'est assez logique vous savez je veux
pas d'être des exemples ce soit aux
états unis ou en france quand vous avez
quand même nouvelles élections au niveau
présidentiel nouvelle équipe qui se met
en place donc c'est assez logique et une
rupture on oublie toujours selon ses
dires ans et ça pose un problème
le deuxième point c'est que le plus
important c'est que l'équipe qui a pris
le pouvoir
derrière le président est vraiment ici
c'est une équipe qui pourra semble
d'entre eux étaient même contre l'accord
2015 vous imaginez ça pose quand même
des problèmes d'ajustement pour avoir un
nouveau discours pour finalement changé
d'avis quoi continuer à soutenir cet
accord 2015 et puis il ya des problèmes
qui sont pas que technique c'est mettre
en place une nouvelle équipe
changer la stratégie quelle stratégie a
changé avoir une stratégie plus dur donc
c'est pas non plus très surprenant que
ces prêts cependant un certain temps et
je pense que ça même partie peut-être la
stratégie iranienne de montrer que pour
finalement c'est pas une priorité
qui sont pas aux abois cause des
sanctions économiques donc je pensais
aussi une stratégie de négociation
l'europe qui se posant en médiateur dans
ce dossier est ce que les européens en
ont les arguments pour faire avancer le
retour des etats-unis dans l'accord de
vienne aujourd'hui
alors oui c'est une très bonne question
je pense pas vraiment moi on joue notre
rôle de médiateur c'est bien on parle de
partie on parle aux états unis on parle
dernier c'est très bien je pense on a
déjà parlé sur votre antenne et je pense
la crédibilité européenne
on ira et notamment vis-à-vis des durées
il est au point le plus bas reste que
pour les durs en iran on n'a absolument
rien fait pour empêcher l'application
des sanctions américaines contre lyon
qui ont conduit le gouvernement iranien
à sortir de là qu'en 2015 donc
voilà on est on est pas trop crédit pour
les pour le pouvoir en iran actuellement
et comment ça se fait que ce soit
l'europe justement qui qui se soit
emparé de cette posture un peu de
médiateur
c'est assez logique c'est un petit lait
avec le retour de maiden on a quand même
on retrouve au centre à l'allié
traditionnel aux états unis donc il ya
quand même une convergence de vues sur
le fait que l'iran va pas obtenir la
leur nucléaire que que les états unis
reviennent de reviennent dans la corde
quelles convergences de vues donc je
pense que c'est assez logique qu'on joue
notre rôle de médiateur mais d'un autre
côté le dit le dirigeant iranien discute
avec la russie discute avec la chine qui
sont aussi signataires de l'accord 2015
alors à la veille de cette rencontre les
etats-unis ont fait planer la menace
militaire contre l'iran s'il a des
plaies si la diplomatie échoue comment
est ce qu'on peut comprendre ce
durcissement de ton aujourd'hui
non mais c'est pas non plus très nouveau
il ya toujours cette idée aux états unis
que si la diplomatie ne marche pas
toutes les options comme ils disent
toutes les options sont sur la table et
parmi toutes ces autres choses soient
table l'action unitaire et sera à terme
est très sérieusement je pense que c'est
pour l'instant c'est pas très crédible
je pense que l'objectif des états unis
c'est vraiment de revenir dans l'accord
2015 et ses 2 voilà de conclure ces
négociations
qui vont sans doute recommencer à vienne
mais qui s'annonce pas facile comme on
l'a dit je pense que l'iran maintenant
avoir une position beaucoup plus dure
vis à vis des occidentaux et quelles
conditions doivent être réunies pour que
le président biden reviennent dans
l'accord
c'est toujours saoul et techniquement
c'est toujours la même chose l'iran
acceptera nord enfin les etats-unis
reviendront dans l'accord 6e
si l'air toutes les sanctions d'un autre
côté si lève toutes les sanctions en
iran reviendra sur toutes les mesures
qui l'ont conduit à commencer à enrichir
l'uranium à 20% à 60% donc c'est
vraiment du donnant donnant les etats
unis doivent lever toutes les sanctions
qu'ils ont prise tout rome contre l'iran
et l'iran de revenir à la situation
initiale vis-à-vis de son problème
nucléaire qui existait au début
début 2018 donc c'est vraiment donnant
donnant le problème c'est que peut-être
les iraniens sont plus dur maintenant
ils vont demander la levée de sanctions
qui sont sans doute pas liée à la
question nucléaire comme le fait que
l'espace d'art ont été mis sur en tant
qu'organisation terroriste
et puis une attitude beaucoup plus dures
de la part des enr en s'éclairant veut
sans doute pas reprendre les
négociations là où elles se sont
arrêtées donc s'il était un peu
compliqué donc ils veulent ils veulent
revenir sur des sujets sur lequel y
avait déjà eu des accords éclairant donc
comme je vous le dit on le
manifestement les négociations
s'annoncent tendues et vont pas être
faciles qu'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
des activités nucléaires en iran
alors que c'est ça qui inquiète si vous
laissez que l'iran normalement d'après
se rappelle qu'avec l'accord l'iran
devait pas enrichir l'uranium à plus de
3 7% qui en gros le niveau qui
correspond à l'actif des civils
maintenant l'iran a commencé à enrichir
l'uranium à 20% même à 60% ils utilisent
ils ont mis en activité des nouvelles
centrifugeuses donc toute la communauté
on va dire sécuritaire dans le monde
s'inquiète du fait que l'iran continue à
acquérir une connaissance qui lui
donnera les possibilités
assez rapidement s'ils le voulaient de
d'acquérir l'armé nucléaire donc il ya
vraiment une inquiétude sur le fait que
l'iran ce soit a franchi 2 de toutes ces
mesures qui était lié à l'accord 2015
mais je rappelle encore jenny sur red
sea lion a dans cette situation si la
réponse logique à la sortie en mai
2010huit des de l'accord 2015 donald
trump que c'est aussi assez paradoxal de
voir les américains aujourd'hui accusé
l'iran de ne pas jouer la diplomatie
passé dire que excusez moi mais qui sème
le vent récolte la tempête sur cc c'est
assez évident qui rend a réagi une
situation de crise de l'économie s'est
effondrée en iran donc sous l'impulsion
des dieux compris le couvre actuellement
en iran l'iran a réagi en sortant de
l'accord 2015
si beaucoup thierry comique pour votre
éclairage je rappelle vous êtes
chercheur à l'iris et l'institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques et vous êtes spécialiste de
l'iran